to be happy and healthy
they need to be able to run
and
maybe just maybe this is
my role in this world is to provide that
for them
my name is tc waite and i'm a dog musher
rescuing these dogs and giving them a
home
is really important
we have right now 23 sled dogs on the
property
we kind of have this
motley crew of
scratch and dent sort of dogs that have
come to us from a variety of different
places
we have a group that have been rescued
we've got some from shelter we've got
some retired racing sled dogs that are
living out their golden years with us in
my mind it's a second chance for these
dogs
are you ready to hurt us
yeah
huskies love to pull a sled
it keeps them active it keeps their mind
focused
this is what they were bred to do over
generations even though they're older or
maybe they can't keep up with a race
team they still love to do it
you don't have to be the prima ballerina
in order to enjoy dance
the way that we make this work is we go
back and forth between colorado and
alaska so in the summer times we're down
south in colorado and hold down jobs and
save all that we can during the summer
so that we can put it away towards
towards the winter we manage to
transport
21 to 22 dogs over 3 000 miles each way
twice a year
i've got friends and family they might
not understand our crazy little life but
they they understand that we're doing
good things for these dogs
there is nothing
like
experiencing a dog team in action
you're
literally dropped into this snow globe
of wilderness that you can explore
and
you get to do it with your best friends
it just makes my heart sing